people think that if they inherently
make higher quality videos that views
and those things will follow and that's
not true because no one knows how high
quality your content is until they've
clicked on the video so first of all you
have to kind of make high value content
which is about the strategy topic title
thumbnail because that's presentation
that's demonstrating high value that's
Optics so what's the standard acceptable
quality in your Niche it may not be
having 4K video but you might be in a
niche that has higher quality Aesthetics
if you're in the tech Niche production
value matters more production value
matters Less in the news niche
so you want to grow your YouTube channel
but maybe you feel stuck or frustrated
because you're not getting the
subscribers you're not getting the views
well in this episode of the think media
podcast Roberto Blake a full-time
Creator and digital entrepreneur is
going to be revealing his secrets for
getting 10 000 subscribers per month he
really has like a three-step system and
then eight tips that he's going to be
breaking down in detail and this comes
out of his new book create something
awesome and so I'm excited to learn his
Secrets Roberto welcome back to the
podcast thanks so much for having me
Sean so before we get into the Practical
steps for this strategy you break down
three things and you say you need a
strategy for growing an audience a
system for passive income and a strategy
for networking explain the 30 000 foot
level here of your journey of growing
your channel and and to 10 000
subscribers a month okay so this is
something that you don't just learn
overnight Sean this was a massive trial
and error so what people need to
contextualize is I've made over 1500
videos on my main YouTube channel and
that in my YouTube Journey where I
started taking YouTube seriously from
2013 to 2016 was where I started taking
it the most seriously and that meant
consistent content not missing like a
week and I did something really insane
and borderline stupid there's a point
where I went to daily content and I kept
that up for a very long time and so what
you need to understand is in three years
I went from like you know
um zero like well not zero but like zero
consistent uploads to where in three
years I've made over 800 videos on
YouTube that's why I ended up with you
know 100 000 subscribers between the
August of 2013 and the April of 2016 and
that's how I got my silver play button
award now after that so it's not a fluke
I consecutively for three more more
years beyond that was growing at a rate
of over 10 000 subscribers a hundred
thousand new subscribers a year for like
three consecutive years so what I'm
referring to Works long term for that
and the thing is Sean
there's a lot I did wrong so like it's
so the thing is there's a lot I did
wrong and everything that I played in
was already saturated on top of that so
for all the excuses that you know the
The Usual Suspects in terms of excuses
no my friends uh this is still doable
and attainable and there are people
doing it all the time but it's not um
easy one of the things you have to
identify even with that content that
your content system and I'm not saying
you have to do it daily but that's one
of the um most effective strategies is
being able to make the right amount of
content for your niche
keep in mind here are things I did wrong
for one thing I wasn't making that daily
content exclusively in one lane for one
audience
if I had done that Sean I'd be at a
million subscribers by now when you
stick to one lane one audience all of
your effort all of your energy is
compounding it's just stacking and it's
just going in One Direction it's just
getting more powerful and more powerful
more powerful I deluded the potential of
my channel my channel had more potential
than it currently has to be much larger
uh that is if I went in only one
exclusive Direction with all of that
content I made so the compounding effect
would be there the other thing is as
much as it gets a bad rap
with search friendly content that's also
Evergreen and not about chasing Trends
it meant that my content gets a longer
shelf life it doesn't get the emotional
upfront satisfying views but it in that
way it works like a very unsexy
investing strategy of just putting your
money into S P 500 not Financial advice
but it's like just you know it's
basically old man Buffett's version of
YouTube it's like so I play Old Man
Buffett's version of YouTube of just
like what if I just dollar cost average
and just uploaded YouTube videos every
day even for the people who think that
YouTube is luck and put winning the
lottery okay Bet so what if you just
bought a lottery ticket every day your
odds are better than someone who does it
once a week your better odds are better
than someone who does it once a month
and thinks this is the big winning
lottery ticket this time oh I finally
have figured out the right numbers it's
like no if you were just playing every
day
then your your odds if you believe in I
don't believe in luck but if you did
your your odds dramatically increase if
you were playing every day or close to
it or three days or five days
comparatively to someone who only plays
once a week so with Evergreen content it
has discoverability long term I think
it's just because it's Evergreen and
search friendly doesn't mean that if you
have a very good thumbnail strategy that
doesn't work on the YouTube homepage if
you have a really good thumbnail it
works on the YouTube thumb page if your
topic is going to get picked up by other
people because the niche has the
potential for the niche itself to grow
over time than when it picks up in
someone that's not you makes a viral
video YouTube's gonna have to look for
suggested videos to put next to a viral
video if you've made more videos on that
one topic than anyone else and that
thing goes viral guess who's the
candidate for the next up page at the
end of the video guess who's the
candidate for the videos next to or
below it and suggested so the thing is
if the category has potential in the
future and you're making good quality
videos acceptable quality for the niche
maybe it's not the highest quality but
if it's the standard of the niche and if
the niche could be on the rise
then that means more people will search
for it more people will view it casually
on the home page and more people will
view it casually and binge watch
suggested videos on the same idea or
topic so you can position Yourself by
going deep and having that repository so
that when everyone decides that that
thing you're passionate about is gold
now you have you own the mine you own
the gold mine you own the silver mine
you own the depth and then everybody
who's chasing it is only boosting your
content in the home page and suggested
because you have the Deep inventory and
you've been around the whole time and
the proof of this Sean is during the
pandemic all those people who made those
boring tutorials on zoom and uh Google
classroom and uh Microsoft uh meet or
group meetings and stuff like that all
these live stream platforms that people
had to use for business meetings uh
conferences uh School of it because it's
my time these people it's their time so
the timing you can be so early to the
market and if it's Evergreen content it
can produce massive riches in the future
if your time should come
so you may not be able to always predict
or anticipate those things but does it
have that potential does it have the
adoption rate and in my case Sean one of
the smart things is tutorial content
because I reverse engineered this in the
fact that I'm an adobe user all I had to
do was like and I didn't think about
this at the time but if you look it up
it's like how many millions Adobe is one
of the biggest tech companies and on the
S P 500 Index how many customers does
Adobe have oh so you mean if I make uh
content for Adobe products as software
tutorials on skills I already have do
you mean that there's already millions
of English-speaking users for this
software and you can do that in a
variety of ways if you realize the
people who are smart in entertainment
they do this with oh Lord of the Rings
is coming out with a new series on
Amazon and I'm already all these lore
channels that have existed as Tolkien
fans for the last almost two decades on
YouTube like for like 17 years there
have been Tolkien fans that have been on
YouTube for 17 years it's their time now
because now there's a new series is it's
bringing a new audience and a new uh
group and fan base for that Game of
Thrones those people are eating again so
because there's lore and there's history
so the content is Evergreen Evergreen
content isn't Just For Education
channels and a lot of people don't
understand that search content isn't
Just For Education channels it can be
for fan bases and communities as well
and so leveraging search doesn't mean
you're not still taking advantage of the
home page that's just a good topic title
and thumbnail as always my friend and as
for suggested videos that's just about a
niche that's on the rise of content that
people would binge watch so make a
candidate for that so that's the that's
the Evergreen you know funnel strategy
um as the the main part and component of
that that we talked about with search
being a factor in that
love it so that's a lot of heat in that
initial opening statement and Evergreen
search based now we're going to go
tactically and you kind of touched on
this but there's practical steps you
broke down for this strategy the first
one was identify a specific Evergreen
Niche to your point if you tapped into
something like Game of Thrones House of
dragons uh dragon just came out you have
Adobe not only is Adobe in the past but
it continues to update its software and
launch new software whole channels could
be devoted just to Premiere Premiere
keeps up doing updates on a separate
note uh Billy rivka actually worked with
think for a while hundred thousand
subscribers just on DaVinci Resolve and
DaVinci uploads uh you know a new they
push a new update and he has 55 new
videos to make or more and you can keep
going deeper so identify a specific
Evergreen niche these are eight steps
number two is perform keyword research
targeting High search volume phrases so
this is the step-by-step thing you did
to build up and you also gave us you
also took Massive Action you put a lot
of outputs out there more at bats you
don't believe in luck but it's like the
harder I work the luckier I get because
you put out more search based videos but
breakdown number two so perform keyword
research targeting High search volume
phrases yes um what can we learn there
so I was a Google AdWords
um certified professional when I worked
in Corporate America I also was a
website designer and developer and I was
an on-site and on off-site SEO guy and I
used to live in Google analytics before
I ever lived in YouTube analytics Sean
for years so before YouTube ever existed
I spent years in Google analytics so
I've been in Google's back end in
systems for over 20 years now Sean and
the funny thing about that and what that
does for you is you start to after you
spend that much time with them you start
to almost think like a Google engineer
or developer and you start to kind of
just like start to see the patterns of
how they build things how they like
their dashboards start to look at top to
bottom left to right and realize wait a
minute that's a priority if they put it
top to bottom left right there's the
first menu I see oh that matters start
to reverse engineer all that being said
with the search side of things I learned
a lot about search I learned a lot about
search based advertising which is what
pays every YouTuber and so I use that to
my advantage now someone without all of
that background could really just think
of this from the same perspective as
somebody who searches for their favorite
product on Amazon their favorite videos
on YouTube their favorite shows on
Netflix and a lot of people they think
SEO is dead they misinterpret a lot of
what YouTube has said publicly and then
if you look at YouTube and Google's own
help documents on their own website it
actually the information suggests that
it is still there the other most
important thing is if Google's
um and YouTube's search and Discovery
mechanisms when it comes to keywords and
tags didn't matter then they wouldn't
give you the option they would eliminate
the field they've taken away 20 features
from YouTube since I've been on the
platform if this one didn't matter they
would have gotten rid of it too so what
I tell people is assume everything
matters but maybe everything doesn't
matter as much as something else I think
the mistake is that people think of if I
do these right tags I will get more
views that's not their purpose
the purpose I believe that this serves
is like everything in retail and YouTube
is retail your videos are products
it's to categorize and contextualize
what you do to someone who might enjoy
it so if you can put things in your
title descriptions and tags and
transcripts
that all correlate it means that your
thing is more relevant and provably more
relevant for the thing that you're
talking about because we can confirm in
all four of these places that you are
talking about the thing you're talking
about so then we know it's not click
bait that's how the system determines
whether something's click bait the other
thing is it's Performance Based so they
look at if you were if you are what you
say you are then you won't have as many
people drop off in the first 30 seconds
so that's another validation that they
use they use timing in that regard as
well uh time on site is what we used to
call it in Google Land We Now call that
YouTube land retention rates so you can
see how my Google expert knowledge
translates over to YouTube now
for paid advertising no less now the
thing about that is people also to
understand that the keywords that you
use also help on the paid ad system
that's somewhat archaic on Google side
in terms of what ads pair with what
videos now that's not the only Factor
obviously your title pays probably the
biggest factor in all these things but
in terms of a verification method there
are keywords and there are keyword
exclusions that advertisers use
so since I know that I know that this
still matters the other thing I know in
terms of this is like okay Robert that's
all great what do I put in my okay
in your Niche what do people search for
if I'm making
um Game of Thrones content House of the
Dragons one of the things I know people
are looking for is they're looking for
individual characters in the series so I
know that I'm going to make character
essays about our favorite
um characters but also what great houses
belong to how Stark House Lannister
house Hightower so on and so forth
there's gonna be people looking for that
there's gonna be people looking for Game
of Thrones fan fiction there's going to
be people looking for Game of Thrones
theories there's going to be people
looking for non-spoiler reviews so I
already know that these are things I
could put in my title and I can
reinforce the variations of how people
search for those things in my keywords
tags and then also I can put variations
of these things in my descriptions if
there's a if there's a title that may
have been more specific but it's too
long maybe that's how I phrase the first
couple lines of my description to
compensate for that maybe I reinforce
those variations or those things in my
tags in YouTube so that someone looking
for it YouTube can identify when it's
thinking did you mean this it has a
point of reference for that did you mean
this when it talks about certain
subjects throughout my
um video the other thing I can do is add
chapters and the thing is if there are
certain things in my chapters that
someone would be looking for if those
things are also in my keyboard tags it
surfaces it much better in YouTube and
in Google because as you know Sean the
reason SEO in search isn't dead and
keywords and tags aren't that is because
Google takes Snippets of your YouTube
video and makes that a result in Google
Search now on top of the video being a
Google Search and on top of the playlist
being a Google search as well now so now
you have all these ways to appear in a
Google search let alone a YouTube search
and the thing is with SEO and these
keywords and tags
they matter because of this ability to
contextualize what somebody might want
to watch
and when you describe a product and you
put in Amazon what are there there are
keywords and their attacks when you look
up a film and Netflix and you want to
say I want to watch Kerry Washington
films I want to watch anything that was
uh made and put out in 1990s I want to
watch uh anything that was directed by
Quentin Tarantino
how would the system know that and know
to deliver that to you based on your
preferences the only way it knows that
is someone went in and labeled this
thing correctly and said this film
has these actors in it and those actors
are Now keywords this film is this genre
this film has this director this film
was made at this time this film uh has
these specific aspects of it this film
is in 4k this film is in standard
definition so so your YouTube video
should have keywords that classify what
the video is about what's included in it
what features it has if it has any of
those collaborators if you have them and
so on and so forth because it is a more
accurate way for the system to serve the
viewer it's not about you gang views
it's about the viewer gang what they
want accurately
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
so number one is you've identified an
evergreen Niche so you're listening to
this you pick out your Niche and the
goal is not only the goal a huge key for
this strategy is that it's Evergreen it
reminds me of growing up in Seattle what
does Evergreen mean we had evergreen
trees so summer spring winter or fall
the the pine needles did not come off of
these trees that are green year-round no
matter how hard hot it gets no matter
how cold it gets the trees stay green
this is powerful about YouTube when you
have Evergreen content more or less
regardless of what happens in the
economy these certain types of videos
continue to get views which means
there's consistency in your income and
so you've identified the Evergreen Niche
number two you perform keyword research
with all with also the goal of
identifying the topics that are getting
higher search volume some of that is
intuition you may have intuition of what
people would be looking for on House of
the Dragons or in regards to Adobe and
you can reinforce that with tools you
you then say number three prioritize
phrases with high search volume but low
competition and number four is build an
evergreen content strategy I'm moving
through this because of course people
could check out your uh book but let's
hit number five now produce content ex
of acceptable quality within the niche
what do you mean by that yes so you have
to identify what is exceptional like
acceptable quality in your Niche so the
thing is people think that if they
inherently make higher quality videos
that views and those things will follow
and that's not true because no one knows
how high quality your content is until
they've clicked on the video so first of
all you have to kind of make high
quality high value content which is
about the strategy topic title thumbnail
because that's presentation that's
demonstrating high value that's Optics
that's branding that's marketing that's
Aesthetics that's thumbnails that's
titles that's attention so high value is
all about getting attention high quality
is about delivering a good experience so
what's the standard acceptable quality
in your Niche it may not be having 4K
video that may not be what people who
have a hundred thousand subscribers have
to do they might be doing standard
definition but you might be in a niche
that has higher quality Aesthetics if
you're in the tech Niche you have to
make higher production value matters
more in the tech Niche production value
matters Less in the news Niche it
matters Less in the politics Niche it
matters Less in the niche of commentary
sometimes
but in the niche of beauty channels
Aesthetics matter so higher production
values in the niche of tech and product
reviews much higher quality required to
be competitive there all right if you're
doing streaming maybe it's not as high
of a quality but if you did go to higher
quality maybe that's something that
helps you stand out and convert more of
the Casual viewers to the subscribers so
the thing is you have to identify in my
Niche was the was the person that is
doing well and is growing maybe they're
not a hundred thousand subscribers yet
but was somebody growing in my Niche was
their content look and sound like okay
what's acceptable quality generally
speaking the Baseline if you just want
to say hey even from day one I want to
look like the creators that I tend to
watch and you tend to watch creators
that have 50 100 000 and have put in
some effort and money into their
presentation so what you're probably
looking at is an investment in a decent
microphone we use good microphones that
investment in a competitive microphone
is probably anywhere from 80 to 500 to
have something that is comparable with
people who have ten thousand fifty
thousand a hundred thousand even up to a
million subscribers people with a
million subscribers most of them are not
using a microphone that's more than 400
500 that sounds like a lot of money I
made that mowing lawns when I was a
teenager Sean it's doable but there are
people who have a hundred thousand
subscribers they're using 80 to 200 300
microphones so take them to Grant salt
and realize that it's like you can get
very competitive at a budget lighting
you can light a perfectly reasonable
YouTube video for a Channel with a
million subscribers with
um one light if you need to uh when we
were at
vidsummit and I was with Omar takori we
borrowed a light from our friends over
at aputure it was like a 300 light it
was the Arman
um 100 or 200 and we borrowed a 100
150 softbox we took that up and we used
one light to light uh both of us and
that was all she wrote and we were good
to go and it was a great video and the
quality was great I think that video has
like 50 000 80 000 views or something
like that so you can be competitive on
the level of the biggest people in your
Niche without spending thousands of
dollars per item you can do that it now
you have to understand
don't try to be the exception that
proves the rule and says I'm going to
get to a million subscribers with
nothing but my iPhone like that's not as
uh statistically likely that's not as
reasonable to do it could happen but
it's not reasonable look at what people
who are successful already and people
who are growing what their standard is
and say if you click on my video after
watching theirs in suggested everyone
wants suggested video views they click
on my video after suggested does the
quality just fall off of a cliff or no
so can I sit there and can somebody
watch any Creator in my niche and the
quality doesn't fall off of a cliff
that's what you're looking for
powerful and as these practical steps
are stacking this is one of my favorites
number six produce quantity more
reliably than competitors yes you
mentioned this earlier you had this
three-year run where you pumped out 800
videos it sounds to me Roberto that you
outworked the competition and there was
probably very few people that if any
that really produced that level of
quantity that reliably break this down
so what happened was
because of what I was doing and then
even beyond that first 100
000 subscribers and why I was able to
replicate that year over year and I
increased the quality year over year too
and I was able to start getting 100 000
subscribers with less videos required to
do it
uh now my Baseline is if I want a
hundred thousand subscribers a year I
have to put out like 100 videos a year
100 somewhere between 100 150 is the new
I would have to put out 300 plus anymore
um so that's about 150. but the the
thing and the reason that works out uh
Sean it depends on your Niche it depends
on your strategy your Effectiveness your
personality performance production blah
blah blah but if you can get to a
baseline of okay I have good production
values I perform well on camera and
there are people like my personality and
I know how many subscribers I get when I
put out this video this video this video
If You Can scale that then you can start
to control the amount of subscribers and
Views and money that you're getting
because now you can say if I'm making
this much with one video a week or two
videos a week if I go to Five if I go to
seven if I go to ten I have a way to
justifiably expect some linear
continuation of those results that's
just how everything typically is now
there are points of diminishing returns
but the thing with YouTube is this every
video is a new opportunity and some
perform better than others so the thing
is there's actually very little proof of
diminishing returns when the quality has
been proven to be acceptable to the
community so the thing is once you get
quality to a point to where it's
acceptable to community and you'll know
that because views are becoming
subscribers and they're becoming them at
a reasonable rate or an above average
rate for your Niche and you see it with
your own eyes
then you know as long as I don't drop
this quality and I do more of it more
results will follow and I can stack my
results now so it's no different than
other work oh wow I'm making this much
money I'm getting these results because
I'm working 20 hours a week well clearly
my salary will increase if I do 40 hours
a week and the productivity doesn't work
and no one's unsatisfied with what I did
and I'm still getting the same customers
compliments in the same standard as
maintained as long as I maintain my
standard increasing the output can only
increase results so that's uh where this
comes in and if your competitors are
obsessed with increasing quality when no
one asks them to if they're chasing
their jail they're the ones who are
going to get frustrated sometimes with
up in the antec because again they're
mistaken quality and value if your ideas
are good enough and people are already
like yes I'm paying attention that I'm
excited about that that's where I would
put more energy is into better ideas not
trying to just oh I need 3 three camera
angles now I need six guys running
around with me it's like you don't
always need that some people do that and
it works but the thing that reliably has
been proven to work Sean is if people
say yes to something
if you give them what they're already
saying yes to more often they'll do that
the other thing is everyone's worried
that that's going to burn out their
subscribers Sean everybody should just
go to their analytics and figure out
that more than 50 of Their audience is
not subscribed to them so continue to
reach new people is how you grow this is
new acquisition it is literally a
numbers game
I don't like the idea of quality over
quantity Sean I think it's a misnomer I
think the main thing is we need to
strive to level up in all areas we need
to produce high value content that gets
attention that the people we want to
reach will care about then we need to
make sure they're having the best
experience possible in terms of the
quality within our abilities within our
abilities without killing ourselves it's
like we gotta we gotta do that and then
with also out exhausting ourselves and
overworking we also have to say now I'm
going to give you that thing that you
give attention to that experience that
you love and I'm going to give you more
of that than anybody else is giving you
and if you can level up in all of those
areas you have a higher chance of being
successful than someone who doesn't
level up in all those areas it's all
about main raising standards and then
maintaining them and scaling in the
right places so I'm going to give you
the last final two these are in uh
Roberto's book highly recommended we'll
link it in the show notes create
something awesome but these eight
practical steps number seven is then
rank multiple videos around an
individual search query and number eight
create more of the content that produces
the most growth for more on this the
entire chapter that breaks this down
kind of narrates the whole story but
Roberto you've added intense value and
some nuances in this episode and so I
want to thank you for all the value
you're adding to the Creator economy and
to the think media podcast Community as
well appreciate you
[Music]